but i want to kind of start from the
beginning your story of coming out as a
first-time employee with them to
eventually become the ceo well thanks
patrick let me uh i'll try to be brief
on it but uh
i initially grew up in the midwest so
kind of had some of those midwest values
and
and always was interested in finance and
being an entrepreneur
and got started in in college buying
homes
uh flipping them
to
build some capital because i figured out
over the long run we all want to try to
generate some capital to do what we can
do and and go from there
uh fortunately i started that process
while i was working learned how to uh
invest in the markets and stocks and all
those things he became familiar with
warren buffett back in the early 70s i
was in the midwest
and then got recruited out to
spokane washington to manage a group of
mutual funds took a little 50-person
company
and over about six years we grew that
dramatically then came up with the idea
that in
about 1981 or so that if we could put
that culture
of
entrepreneurism together with a bank we
could really create something special
and i searched around a little bit and
found a failing near failing thrift in
the seattle area called washington
mutual it was losing 30 million a year
the fdic said it had 18 months left
before but i said i think this is
something we could do something with
so we put the companies together
i was able to roll all of my stock that
i had remember i took those houses
created that capital put that into it
was actually murphy favors the name and
we rolled that then into washington
mutuals and so we ended up becoming
significant uh particular equity holders
in washington mutual
and uh it was still a mutual company and
we said you know what let's take it
public which we did
i remember because i had a cost basis
the stock about 40 cents a share
and we took the company public and
ultimately grew the market cap to about
40 billion dollars
so it was a pretty uh interesting deal
but from the consumer side what we
wanted to do is put together a broad
product line including the things the
securities and insurance industries have
together with the bank and have a little
more customer focused uh
look at things and we grew that customer
base pretty dramatically up to about 11
million customers
and in the early 2000s we were growing
right at a million customers per year
and it built the branching system up to
2200
and was earning about four billion
dollars a year
so it was a pretty good uh pretty good
deal uh as you said we had we received
every award you could imagine
about best quality of service best
products because we always tried to give
the consumer the best deal out there
either in terms of pricing better
service we tried to have our employees
uh both engaged but uh trying to be a
little higher on the customer service
front so we got all the jd powers
awarded the best uh customer service and
all those things
anyway that was all the good stuff and
that turned out to be part of our
achilles heel
because as it turns out the the moneyed
politicians and east coast people
really felt threatened because we moved
into new york we were taking huge market
share from jpmorgan chase from citigroup
from all those guys
and uh the new york regular banking
regulars didn't like us too much we
weren't there uh kind of folk we didn't
uh we weren't blue bloods from harvard
and
and east coast schools we were trying to
do stuff for the consumer and we can go
more into depth if you want that turned
out to be a problem for us when the
financial crisis hit
and
in what way so was it was it main street
versus wall street where
you were not in the circle of wall
street and you were kind of rubbing them
the wrong way were they not fans of
yours absolutely in fact in our book we
used
and then some
testimony i did when we were talking to
congress and all that i coined the
phrase we were not too clubby to fail
and uh just saying it look at there's an
east coast club it's a pay-to-play game
yeah you uh there was a direct
correlation of who benefited from who
gave the most political money uh to the
guys down there and and i think they're
a little threatened by this growth of
this west coast uh uh outfit that was uh
was kind of eaten at their uh eating
their lunch
and uh and then when the uh the
financial crisis hit
uh we saw
politicians regulators everybody was
panicked
went outside of any normal protocols
they have of what they're supposed to do
and the like and they
you know i feel very strongly that they
just inequitably and unfairly treated
washington mutual and tried to find any
excuse they could to give them a
sweetheart deal and give it over to
jpmorgan chase so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast
click right here
[Music]